a Republican lawmaker just killed
himself after sexual molestation
allegations Joe Biden makes a power move
and Democrats are getting out a little
bit over their skis over Alabama I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
okay so we have a lot to get to today as
always a crazy article from The New
Yorker a bizarre sort of study that
comes out from the New York Times that
makes no sense whatsoever and of course
this crazy story about a GOP state Rep
and I guess Kentucky who shot and killed
himself after allegations of sexual
molestation will talk about all of that
and the fallout but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at man
crates so this is one of my favorite
sponsors obviously not just because
they're called man crates but also
because they're super cool man crates
calm it's the surest way to get gifts
that guys will actually love guaranteed
it's not a cheese of the Month Club it's
not a new tie or a sweater now for over
a hundred hand curated gift collections
for every type of guy from the rugged
outdoorsman to the sports fanatic and
everything in between
they have the whiskey appreciation crate
with it personalized to cancer and
glasses for your favorite drink or the
grillmaster crate with a brass knuckle
meat tenderizer and a cast-iron smoker
box to all man's stuff so here's the one
that I got which is pretty awesome I
have this look at this an ammo box okay
and inside this ammo box poker stuff
okay so first I have to make some
friends once I do that it's gonna be
awesome so here it is check that out oh
yeah man crates they're pretty amazing
and again if you think this is cool they
have all sorts of different options for
a variety of people and types so you can
check that out if I can ever get this
closed again bear boom man man crates
love it everyone agrees that these are
these presents are amazing and they have
thousands of five-star reviews every man
crate comes with a high-five guarantee
of course go-to man crates calm slash
men get five percent off your order
that's five percent off your order at
man crates calm slash man that's man
crates calm slash Ben get five percent
off your order and you too can become a
real man with man crates calm or it can
at least make your spouse or your
boyfriend or your dad feel good okay so
this is a crazy story it broke last
night apparently there was a GOP
lawmaker in Kentucky who shot himself
days after denying allegations of sexual
misconduct so according to a report from
a local radio station
his name is representative Dan Johnson
and he reportedly shot and killed
himself on a bridge in Mount Washington
Kentucky police told WDRB they've
recovered the gun that he used on Monday
the content
Center for Investigative Reporting
published an expose with an accuser who
is a friend of his daughter saying that
Johnson raped her when she was 17 she
alleged the assault took place in 2012
and New Year's Eve sleepover party when
he was a pastor Johnson dismissed the
allegation he said this allegation
concerning this lady this young girl
absolutely has no merit it is the season
last election it seemed to be racism
this election it seems to be sexual
impropriety he left a suicide note as
well and the suicide note was was heavy
on God reference as he basically said
the accusation here's what the suicide
note said he posted it on his Facebook
page before shooting himself obviously
when we were due to it after shooting
himself so the accusations from NPR are
false God and only God knows the truth
nothing is the way they make it out to
me America will not survive this type of
judge and jury fake news conservatives
take a stand I love God and I love my
wife who's the best wife in the world my
love forever my mom and dad my family
and all five of my kids and nine
grandchildren too in tummies and many
more to come each of you or a total gift
from God stay strong Rebecca needs you
911 911 2001 New York City WTC PTSD 24/7
16 years is a disease that will take my
life I cannot handle it any longer it
has won this life but heaven is my home
please listen closely only three things
I ask of you to do if you love me is
quote blame no person Satan is the
accuser so blame the devil himself
forgiven loved everyone especially
yourself most importantly love God PS I
love my friends who our family God loves
all people no matter what so I'm gonna
go out on a limb here and say this guy
had some mental trouble before he shot
himself
the reason I'm gonna say that is because
of references like 9/11 PTSD 24/7 16
years of sickness that will take my life
I can't handle it any longer it's it's
obviously a tragedy for the guy's family
it does raise the question as to what
standard of proof we're going to hold
for politicians because one of the big
problems that we've seen is so many
people saying that Roy Moore was
innocent for example in Alabama because
they didn't want to believe all of the
evidence that been brought forth by
accusers it is absolutely rational and
reasonable to say that you don't have to
believe all women okay when I sit what
meaning not all women are equally
credible because not all people who
accuse people of crimes are equally
credible not all men are equally
credible this believe all women stick
it's a little bit strong if we believe
to all women and then stopped our
evidentiary findings of that we would
just be jailing guys willy-nilly without
any due process whatsoever and in the
public's view
would be throwing people out of the
public sphere without any regard for the
credibility of the accusers at all I saw
Joe Biden trying to take advantage of
this sort of moral panic that's set in
by saying he wishes he had done more for
Anita Hill over to the Clarence Thomas
allegations the allegations about
Clarence Thomas that out is that
Clarence Thomas once made a remark I
believe about a pubic hair on a coke can
and this was supposed to make sure that
he was not a Supreme Court justice and
it turns out that there are a lot of
serious questions about a Nita Hills
story they've now made a documentary
about her on HBO if Democrats are trying
to say that that Clarence Thomas should
step down over all of this without any
real evidence that any of this ever
happened the evidence is very sketchy at
best for money to help so we do have to
be careful with all of this the reason
that I said I said this all along the
reason that I thought the Roy Moore
allegations were true is because Roy
Moore did a very poor job of defending
himself there were a multiplicity of
allegations all of the verifying details
were present now is it possible then Roy
Morrison isn't sure it's possible he was
innocent it's possible but I don't think
it was probable but we have to have an
evidentiary standard in our own head I
think Tucker Carlson made this point
last night pretty well he said that he'd
been falsely accused of sexual
harassment before and he told his story
maybe all of these people are guilty as
charged
sexual harassment is real and apparently
common so it could be how common is it
well it would be nice to know that but
that would require facts which are one
of the many things these cases lack
along with names and dates and the
specific nature of the crimes alleged
details matter because in the end they
add up to proof proof is what ensures
that the innocent aren't punished and
protecting the innocent is the very
essence of Western justice unfortunately
we are moving in the opposite direction
toward a standard where to be accused
means to be judged guilty and one of the
big problems with the conflation between
sexual harassment and sexual assault is
that we actually have statistics on
sexual assault and it is not nearly as
common as the media are making it out to
be I mean the number of women in the
United States have been raped is
extraordinarily low by percentage every
one of those an evil act every rapist
should be castrated or killed in my
opinion at least jailed for life but the
the problem that we have here is that
there are no standards that are being
applied the stand the only standard that
seems to be applied is what is useful
and what is not politically now again
should we be taking all of this stuff
seriously yes when the accuser comes for
we should take it seriously because
there are cases where politicians are
really responsible for evil things and
yes it goes hidden for years and years
and years I mean the case in point would
be Denny Hastert it came out that Dennis
Hastert was the former House Speaker
right from a Republican House Speaker he
has now been banned from having contact
with anyone under 18 years of age unless
an adult is present who's aware that he
pled guilty and a hush money case
related to the sexual abuse of teen boys
according to new restrictions imposed by
a federal judge the restrictions state
quote Michelle not have contact with any
person under the age of 18 except in the
presence of a responsible adult who's
aware of the nature of his or her
background and current offense and who
has been approved by the probation
officer and treatment provider he never
faced sexual abuse charges because the
statute of limitations had expired but
he did plead guilty in October 2015
Hastert destructuring bank transactions
to pay off an accuser now the reason
that I bring all of this up is because I
think that as these accusations become
more and more common and more and more
covered and as people leap to knee-jerk
responses about particular politicians
or people we do have to think about how
easy would be to manipulate the system
you know it would be relatively easy to
manipulate the system because
male-female relations are not always cut
and dry it would not be that difficult
for some for a woman and a man to
perceive relationships in different ways
and then for the woman to tell all of
her friends in the way that she
perceived it and suddenly you have an
account that she says she was raped and
she told all of her friends at the time
the guy says wait a second that was
consensual one of the things that I
think is a problem is avoiding the
necessary thinking that we have to do
about these issues in order to virtue
signal so one of the people whose virtue
signalling today is Morgan Spurlock
Morgan Spurlock of course at the
documentary filmmaker and he wrote this
letter on Twitter telling readers that
he wasn't asking who will be next
he was asking when will they come for me
this is his way of doing the Mia culpa
the way that he is doing a Maher culpa
is by basically saying that he's part of
the problem right this is the way that
he's gonna get off is by virtue
signaling not by asking serious
questions about whether he actually
heard a woman or whether he did
something wrong or whether he's being
falsely accused but instead by simply
saying I'm just going to assume that I
did something wrong he now let me off
the hook and you're gonna see more and
more men doing this and it doesn't
actually solve the problem as to what
sort of behavior is acceptable and what
sort of behavior isn't so here's
moorlands Morgan Spurlock's letter that
he posted on Twitter bit by bit he said
as I sit around watching
laughter hero man after man followed the
realization of their past indiscretions
I don't sit by and wonder who will be
next I wonder when will they come for me
you see I've come to understand after
months of these revelations that I am
NOT some innocent bystander and I'm also
part of the problem and whenever
somebody says I'm part of the problem
you can bet that they actually did
something they want to cover up for and
now they're gonna get out in front of it
here's what he says I'm sure I'm not
alone in this thought but I can't act
blindly as though I didn't somehow play
a part in this and if I'm going to truly
represent myself as someone who was
built a career in finding the truth it's
time for me to be truthful as well I'm
part of the problems this is the third
time already he's saying is part of the
problem he's over my life there have
been many instances that parallel what
we see every day in the news when I was
in college whoo girl who I hooked up
with on a one-night stand accused me of
rape not outright there were no charges
or investigations but she wrote about
the instance in a short story writing
class and called me by name a female
friend who was in the class told me
about it afterward I was floored that's
not what happened I told her that wasn't
how I remembered it at all in my mind
we'd been drinking all night and then
went back to my room we began fooling
around she pushed me off we laid in the
bed and talked and laughed some more and
then began fooling around again we took
off our clothes she said she didn't want
to have sex we laid together and talked
and kissed and laughed and then we
started having sex lite-brite she said
what lite-brite that toys it that kids
turned it's all I can see and think
about she said and then she started to
cry I didn't know what to do we stopped
having sex and I rolled beside her I
tried to comfort her to make her feel
better
I thought I was doing okay I believe she
was feeling better she believed she was
raped that's why I'm part of the problem
well that's not really clarifying the
issue right now it's basically saying
that a woman's subjective perception of
a situation which can be interpreted in
a variety of different ways we as the
public are simply supposed to believe
that subjective account you can't
destroy people's lives or careers based
on subjective accounts of events that
are in conflict this is where we get
into some really dicey and uncomfortable
territory because we all know sexual
assault is bad we all know the sexual
harassment is bad and I'm you know a
fortunate guy I've never been in any of
these scenarios right I was a virgin
until I was married a famously one of
most famous virgins until marriage in
American history probably you know and
then that was yeah I think a good
decision one of the reasons I think it
was a good decision is because I don't
have any instances like this in my past
but you can see how any subjective
interpretation of a problem can now
become a national issue its Myrtle Locke
says there was a time I settled a sexual
harassment allegation in my office this
is around eight years ago and I wasn't
it wasn't a groupie feely harassment it
was verbal and it was just as bad well I
don't know that that is just as bad
right if you say
a woman I really don't think that's just
as bad as groping woman's breasts for
example he said I would call my female
assistant hot pants or sex pants when I
was yelling to her from the other side
of the office right so he's a pig but I
think there's a difference between a pig
and somebody who is evil per se says
something I thought was funny at the
time but then I realized that completely
demean him a little turn to a place of
non-existence right so this is you being
a douchebag this is objective right the
reasonable man standard says you are a
douchebag right if you do this sort of
stuff that you're a bad guy if you do
this sort of stuff but he's conflating
subjective interpretations of open
events with objective verifiable
situations where he's being a bad guy
but he says I'm part of the problem then
there's the infidelity I've been
unfaithful to every wife and girlfriend
I've ever had and now this just turns
into him coming out as now he's I mean
talk about virtuous signaling virtuous
signaling is where he confess every sin
that you've ever done in order so that
you look virtuous right he says over the
years I would look at each of them in
the eye and proclaim my love and then
have sex with other people behind their
backs I hurt them and I hate it but it
didn't make me stop the worst but why
like why isn't he telling this to his
priest why is he telling this to us does
the worst part is I'm cons and someone
who consistently hurts those closest to
me for my wife to my friends to my
family and my partners and coworkers
I've helped create a world of disrespect
to my own actions and I am part of the
problem and what caused me to act this
way is it all ego or was it the sexual
abuse I suffered as a boy and a young
man in my teens there we go abuse that I
only ever told that my first wife for
fear is being seen as weak or less than
a man's and now we're gonna blame his
past for all the decisions that he's
been making is it because my father left
my mother when I was a child that she
believed he never respected her so that
disrespect carried over into their son
or is it because I've been consistently
drinking since the age of 13 and the
sexual dalliance is were they meaningful
or did they only serve to try and make a
weak man feel stronger I don't know none
of these things matter when you chip
away at someone and consistently make
them feel like less of a person I am
part of the problem we all are this sort
of sort of gut spilling that's happening
now I don't think that it's particularly
helpful to the conversation we as a
society are going to have to determine
what we think is objectively verifiable
what evidence we find on behalf of
particular allegations what standard of
behavior is it now requires us to end
somebody's career or damage their
livelihood and then we're gonna have to
stick with that because what I don't
like is this constantly shifting
standard by which only the only thing
that matters is the sort of is the sort
of uncomfortable realizations people
come to
then we let them off the hook or the or
the idea that every subjective
interpretation of a series of events
must be taken with equal credibility
okay before I go any further here I'll
talk about to follow from Alabama first
I don't say thank you to our sponsors
over at the u.s. CCA
so can you say with a hundred percent
confidence that you and your family and
your home are safe what if you are
forced to pull the trigger what if
something breaks in your house you have
to shoot them do you know exactly what
to say when the cops arrive look these
aren't important things every
responsible gun owner should know you'll
find all the answers in the u.s. CCA
complete firearms and family defense
guide you're gonna miss your chance to
get yours completely free unless you act
right now go over to defend my family to
calm right now defend my family now
decide defend my family now to calm the
digit to defend my family now
to calm in this 164 page free guide
you'll get how to detect attackers
before they see you safest and most
dangerous places to sit in a restaurant
how to responsibly own and store a gun
even if you have small children
particularly if you have small children
again you have to hurry if you want to
get that free copy defend my family now
to calm to get yours before it's gone
defend my family now to.com get that
before it is gone okay so meanwhile in
in Alabama the fallout continues and it
is pretty obvious that everyone on the
Democratic side is a little bit
overeager a lot of people on the
Republican establishment side are a
little bit overeager we'll start with
the Republicans so bob Corker of course
comes out and he says that he's really
really truly happy with the result in
alabama
i've tried to reach dick shelby this
morning to let him know how proud I am
of his state and and what he did and
again I I know this is not something
that I know we're supposed to cheer for
our side of the aisle if you will but
I'm really really happy with what
happened for all of us in our nation for
people serving in the Senate to not have
to deal with what likely we were going
to have to deal with should the outcome
have been the other way okay so this
kind of stuff from establishment
Republicans only gives more fire to the
fuel the more fuel to the fire rather of
the Steve ban and wing of the Republican
Party of the Roy Moore wing of the
Republican Party you know that this idea
that you're supposed to be happy about
what happened in Alabama I think is is
huge mistake by a quote-unquote
establishment Republicans like worker
you can be upset that a Democrat just
took the office you can be happy that
Roy Moore is not in office you can think
that that was a terrible choice that was
foisted upon the vast majority of
Alabamans most of whom stay at home but
to be overtly happy that a pro-abortion
Democrats at that Senate seat I don't
think is appropriate again I think if he
had said I'm happy Roy Moore lost but
I'm not happy the Doug Jones is in the
Senate I think that's perfectly
appropriate yeah I'm also happy the
Republicans don't have to deal with the
specter of an alleged child molester
among their ranks making headlines every
day for conservatives but I think that
for bob corker to go out on a limb and
say that he's happy all together with
the full result in Alabama is a mistake
and all its gonna do is it's gonna lead
a lot of people on the right side of the
aisle to say oh look at these
establishment Kooks they're fine with
losing they like losing it's because
they wanted to lose right the real
motivation here is they wanted to lose
the seat and they were just using Roy
Moore as an excuse they really want to
stop Trump that's the logic that a lot
of people in the band and wing of the
party want to use it's not correct but
bob Corker lends it credence and I think
that's a mistake he's not the only one
by the way John McCain came out and he
was he was ripping on president Trump's
talk of fake news I've been similarly
critical but here's what John McCain
tweeted he said press freedoms annual
report shows record number of
journalists in prison worldwide and 27
in 2017 including 21 on fake news
charges President must understand is
harmful rhetoric only empowers
repressive regimes to jail reporters and
silence the truth I think again this is
nonsense this is blaming Trump for stuff
that is not really Trump's fault I don't
like Trump's fake news schtick when he
applies it to real news I don't like him
applying it to full outlets like saying
CNN is fake news a lot of stuff on CNN
is fake news but CNN itself is not fake
news you can't discount every fact of a
reported on CNN but the idea that Turkey
is imprisoning journalists because Trump
is saying the words fake news is absurd
all these repressive dictatorial regimes
are gonna do that anyway blaming Trump
is really a foolish thing again this is
what drives people to believe that they
need to support people like Roy Moore
because the establishment is so
all-fired out to get Trump or so
all-fired out to lose seats because they
want to stop the quote unquote trumpian
agenda even though there's no real
agenda now it's not just establishment
Republicans who are overeager here it's
also Democrats who are overeager so
Democrats have been making fools of
themselves
in the aftermath of the
Jones election they think that now it's
gonna be nothing but victories from here
on in and so they're ratcheting up the
rhetoric now they think they're gonna
get Trump now what they don't understand
is there is a major difference between a
presidential election and a Senate
election there's a serious difference
between a White House election and a
Senate election in Alabama how do we
know this because Donald Trump was
alleged to have done a lot of very
improper and nasty things
he won anyway hey if Roy Moore had been
running against doug jones in a national
election for the presidency I'm not sure
that Doug Jones loses I mean I'm not
sure the jugg doug jones win because
again once the stakes are raised that
means more people are gonna show up
regardless as I said yesterday if the
dog catcher race and Roy Moore runs he
loses by a thousand points if it is a
local City Council race and he runs he
loses by five hundred points if it is a
Senate race he loses by two percentage
points and if it's a presidential race
I'm not sure he loses it all we tend to
ignore the stuff that we don't like
about people for partisan purposes the
more important in the office becomes but
Democrats are now thinking that they can
use the Roy Moore playbook against
Donald Trump
so Tom Perez over at the DNC he says the
Trump isn't just a bad president he's
the worst president in American history
what do you say to progressives you want
to have a message that's not just anti
Trump which I'm guessing also means it's
not just about impeachment what do you
tell those in the Democratic base
sensation no no mr. chairman they do
want to talk impeachment what do you say
to them well I say to them here's where
we agree this is the worst president
perhaps in American history this this
tax paid to wealthy people and very
large corporations that don't need it is
an abomination the worst president in
American history the worst president
we've we've had presidents like James
Buchanan we can stop him here he's an
idiot we've had presidents like James
Buchanan we've had presidents like
Andrew Johnson who was impeached we've
had presidents like LBJ who's a
disastrous president we've had
presidents like Woodrow Wilson another
disastrous president we've had Jimmy
Carter be our president like there are
there a lot of really bad press
President Obama's on that list by the
way I don't think Obama is the worst
president in American history
I think Obama's top five bad but I don't
think he's the worst president in
American history there are a lot of
presidents have been more damaging than
President Obama but the idea that Donald
Trump is the worst president after a
year what's he done that makes him the
president in American history only he's
been a great president by any stretch of
the imagination I'd we've had to grade
him now I give him at a c-minus I like
some of the things that he's done I
think he's undercut that with a lot of
his rhetoric I think if you'd stop
tweeting and stop talking he'd be a
b-minus president but the idea that he's
the worst president American history
this is Democrats and getting ahead of
themselves and if they think that
they're gonna be able to defeat Trump
just by shouting at him they tried that
in the last election cycle and it did
not work you see Bernie Sanders is doing
this too
he's now accusing Trump of having severe
emotional problems like why exactly a
kook
old socialist a nutcase who honeymoon in
the USSR and goes around talking about
how we need to pay for everyone's
college make College free without any
plan to pay for it how he's talking
about the serious emotional problems of
Donald Trump is beyond me you got a
president who has been accused by many
many women of harassment to say the
least this is a guy who was on a take
seen by everybody in America essentially
bragging about his sexual assault of
women do I think under those
considerations of Al Franken resigned do
I think the president should resign I do
do I think he will I don't but yes I do
think he should resign you should design
because severe emotional the Democrats
who are pushing this this heart that
Trump should resign that he has to go
there could be a backlash here to the
the overreach there really could and
when I say backlash the overreach I'm
talking also about the media overreach
her because the media overreach er is
pretty astonishing I mean though the
level of media overreach is pretty
insane so I want to show you some some
of the things the media have been saying
about this Alabama race because they're
truly quite nuts so first of all I'll
start with this tweet that just came out
this is about Trump not the Alabama race
David Leonhardt who is a pretty good
reporter over at the New York Times or
can be from time to time he says that
after we published a list of Trump lies
in this summer some of his supporters
assets to compare Trump's now the
president we've done someone just
published the results there's a chart it
shows Trump has lied 103 times in his
first year it says in his first ten
months Trump will hold nearly six times
as many falsehoods as Obama did during
his entire presidency it says Obama only
told eighteen lies his entire presidency
and then you wonder why people don't
trust the media you wonder why when the
media go berserk the media don't pay any
attention to it it's because of
stupidities like this you wonder why
Trump says
News and everybody sort of nods along
it's because that's big news if you
think President Obama only told the 18
license and higher presidency that's
insipid it's absurd if you want to say
he's a bigger liar than Obama you can
probably make a statistical case for it
but to say that in eight years Obama
told eighteen lies that he only told the
lie like twice a year you have got to be
kidding me
you've got to be kidding me that Trump
is told 103 that is not a real statistic
in any sense and you can see that the
media are more than happy to tear Trump
down there is a backlash to that that
backlash only applies to Trump by the
way it didn't help relieve amma it may
have helped them a little bit but not
enough
it doesn't help Republicans in Virginia
the anti media line only helps with the
president because the president really
does have is really receiving the brunt
of media criticism but if Roy Moore says
the media is coming after me and what it
turns out is that there are some pretty
significant allegations against him that
just doesn't wash that said the media
obviously are attempting to tear down
Trump so the Democrats who think that
Roy Moore is the beginning of the end
for Trump no I mean Scott Brown won the
Republican 1/8 Senate seat Ted Kennedy's
old Senate seat in Massachusetts Barack
Obama was re-elected to the presidency
two years later so the idea that Trump
is done as president is just foolish
especially if the media continue to go
crazy over Trump as much as they have so
for example last night we found out that
Omarosa who was a contestant on The
Apprentice and then was in the White
House for nearly a year she had left the
White House there was a story by April
Ryan who really hates Homer rosa
suggesting that Omarosa had been
forcibly objected by ejected by Secret
Service from the White House Secret
Service denied this but you can see the
chortling on CNN over what appears to
have been a fake news Brooke I'm gonna
go speech you can't do and what April
and April Simone are too good of people
to do and that's just gonna be petty for
a minute on the podcast April but bye
honey you have never represented the
community you are skin folk we don't own
you like Dora goodbye good writtens
goodbye Angela Angela you know I have
much love for you but you know what I
don't delight to anyone's demise that
I'm not gonna lighten her demise I wish
her the best but
no no again okay you can see all of the
anchors chortling and laughing oh look
somebody got fire black woman got fired
from the Trump administration and she
deserves to go they're not the only ones
Robin Roberts this morning on Good
Morning America
she actually said bye Felicia about
about Omarosa and she goes bye Felicia
right before she goes to break I mean
like the chortling over Omarosa is
really kind of galling and we're getting
the same routine from MSNBC squares
Matthews at Trump's on the ropes she
just resides you just leave and got in
the morning coming with a show come on
air my suit all wrinkled don't even own
an iron I didn't iron far he's coming
here I don't even I didn't go to sleep
in a bed I just sleeping this chair with
the rolling wheels on the bottom they
just they roll me over
they wake me up and they go boom hard
bunk go Chris Matthews go you think we'd
be better off for this president simply
resigned after all this concern about
his behavior in the past in his current
comments and turn it over to vice
president pence would we be better off
did not want to see this president gone
place I'm favor these investigations or
people are talking about and certainly
the investigation we're seeing on Russia
and that's the only way we're going to
be able to see a change as if the facts
come out and there is in fact a reason
through Congress for some kind of
proceeding and right now that's what we
have to what happen but at the same time
we cannot let go and this is the message
we heard from Alabama and Virginia it's
economic message of people that want us
to simply focus on these
bread-and-butter issues and to stand up
for them every step of the way okay so
this idea that he's going to resign that
were one second away from resignation
it's one of the reasons why the
Democrats have placed so much heavy
burden on the Russia investigation they
think that there are five seconds away
from impeaching Trump Bret Stevens has
an interesting column over at the New
York Times Stevens of course is maybe
the last remaining quote unquote never
Trumper
so one of the one of the distinctions
that people have been making one of the
moving labels people have been using
wrongly in the same way that
neoconservative came to mean anyone who
is for the Iraq war even though
neoconservative originally meant a bunch
of people who are Marxists who became
conservative when they were
disillusioned by leftism
it now became you know anyone who backed
the Iraq war the term never Trump or has
been applied to a bunch of people who
are not quote-unquote never Trump
don't spend their days trying to take
down Trump so I was never Trump during
the election cycle meaning I didn't vote
for the president in the in the general
election or in the primary but once he
was the president that no longer applies
right never Trump just met my vote it
didn't mean my support it didn't mean my
belief that he could change didn't mean
my support for his various policies
there are a few people who are quote
unquote never Trump who sort of
maintained this position that nothing
Trump does can ever be right Bret
Stevens seems to be one of them over at
the New York Times and I like a lot of
Brett's work but that's the position
that he's taken but he has a column
today where he says the Democrats are
making a huge mistake if they think the
Trump is just gonna be ousted because
they don't like him or because his
approval rating is 35% they're
neglecting the fact that the economy is
still booming under President Trump
they're neglecting the fact that a solid
tax cut will help the economy that we
had 3.3 percent GDP growth in the last
quarter that the stock market is at
record highs he says with the economy
good if Trump could shut his mouth for
five seconds he'd win reelection and he
could do so relatively easily because
his governance has not been nearly as
controversial or as difficult as have
been as has been the the rhetoric that
has surrounded him and he's exactly
right about that you know so the only
person who can really get Trump in
trouble and continue to get Trump in
trouble is Trump one of the ways you
could do that is theoretically by
following a firing Robert Muller now as
I mentioned yesterday there is this text
message that was sent from a member of
the Muller team to his fionna to his
mistress he's married his mistress in
which he talked about having an
insurance policy against Trump winning
in in August of 2016 it's not clear what
that meant but it's pretty clear that
the Muller investigation is compromised
to a significant degree that doesn't
mean that Trump has the political
wherewithal to actually fire Robert
Muller and he's gonna have a tough time
doing it considering that his Justice
Department doesn't want to do it rod
Rosen seeing the Deputy Attorney General
he came out yesterday and testimony and
said that he had not seemed good cause
for Trump to fire Muller at this point
in testimony before the Senate Judiciary
Committee you said that you would only
fire special counsel Muller for good
cause and that you had not seen any yet
several months have passed since then
have you seen good cause to fire special
counsel Muller no thank you if you were
ordered today to fire mr. Muller what
would you do
previously I would follow the regulation
if there were good cause I would act if
there were no good cause I would not and
you've seen no good cause so far correct
thank you okay so he's basically saying
that if Trump wants to fire Muller he's
gonna have to do it himself now as I'll
explain later Trump does have the power
to to fire mower he has an enormous
amount of discretion in fact he could
actually call up Muller right now not
just fire Muller he could he could call
it Muller now and say I want you to drop
this investigation this investigation is
over
he could actually just do that he would
even have to fire him he could call him
up and order him to drop the
investigation and then if Moe refused
then he could fire him I'll explain that
a little bit later in the big idea but
the thing that is really important to
notice here is that the Democrats are
hanging their hat on an investigation
that has already fatally compromised
whether or not from fires Muller so the
Roy Moore is out there for Donald Trump
is done that line is is not gonna wash
that's it's not gonna play that's not
how this stuff works
right Republicans thought that after Ken
Starr Clinton was done he left office of
the 66 percent approval rating he picked
up seats in 1998 elections and Al Gore
should have won the 2000 election if he
hadn't been one of the worst candidates
ever if he hadn't actually been a
walking block of wood okay so I now want
to turn to what is to me one of the more
insane pieces I have seen recently the
the social left wants to have it both
ways on the one hand they want to say
that sexual promiscuity and sexual
liberation is a grand and glorious thing
for everyone involved on the other hand
they want to say that everyone's
subjective perception of sexual conduct
must be taken seriously well you can't
have it both ways either sex is
generally a good so long as it is
quote-unquote consensual and they never
define exactly what level of consent is
necessary because sometimes they say
Monica Lewinsky could consent sometimes
they say she couldn't sometimes they say
thirteen-year-old girls can consent
sometimes they say they can't but in any
case the left has this is weird ethos
where they know bad when they see it
they have a Potter Stewart ethic with
regards that powder Stuart's the guy who
said that he couldn't define pornography
but he knew it and when he saw it the
left has that with regard to sexual
ethics more broadly so evidence of this
Zoey Heller is a columnist for The New
Yorker and she writes an entire piece
called in defense of adulterers I talked
about how adultery is natural and normal
and probably good so she starts off by
talking about how our increasingly less
centrist behavior has not been reflected
in more tolerant
like attitudes toward infidelity we
become considerably more relaxed about
premarital sex gay sex and interracial
sex but our disapproval of extramarital
sex has been largely unaffected by our
growing propensity to engage in it we're
eating forbidden apples more hungrily
than ever but we slap ourselves with
every bite according to a 2007 teen
Gallup poll Americans deplore adultery
at much higher rates than they do
abortion animal testing or euthanasia
now by the way I think adultery is less
of us in than abortion because murder
outranks adultery in the pantheon but in
any case this columnist writes that the
the there's something about is altering
that we need to get over we just need to
get over adultery and then they wonder
why it is that men are not taking
seriously admonitions about sexual
morality in order for men to act in
sexual immoral fashion or for women to
act in sexually immoral fashion that
must be built into a society that
suggests male and female roles and what
sexes role in life is okay I think that
you can come up with a series of do
shalt not write thou shalt not do X now
shalt not see why but the problem is a
definitional one when you say thou shalt
not commit adultery well what about an
open marriage is that adultery or thou
shalt not commit what if the wife is
really mean to you what if your husband
is not so nice and has been and has not
been helping you out at home the problem
is that we as human beings have a strong
tendency to redefine terms so thou shalt
nots may seem cleaner on paper but in
practice they get very unclear once
human brains wrap around them which is
why you need an entire system of thought
you need a worldview in order to
effectuate thou shalt nots and we think
that we can basically say thou shalt not
on a societal level and everybody will
follow it we can see that's not the case
we've been saying thou shalt not
sexually harassed for the last 50 years
in the United States obviously that
hasn't stopped a lot of men who have
redefined sexual harassment and now
we're redefining it again and now women
are redefining sexual harassment stuff
they said was not sexual harassment ten
years ago he's being treated as sexual
harassment now and vice versa in any
case this this New Yorker columnist
writes traditional couples therapy
focuses on the defense and enforcement
of the monogamous pact and tends to side
firmly and explicitly with the faithful
spouse he or she is often referred to as
the injured party while the strang
partner is labeled the perpetrator right
cuz you know adultery the standard
assumption is that the affair is a
symptom either of marital dysfunction or
some pathology on the part of the
perpetrator sex addiction and fear of
intimacy are the most common diagnosis
of a lately genetic predisposition
he's been getting traction this approach
rights in author whom the Esther Perel I
guess is the author of a book on
adultery in this book review this
approach Esther Perel believes does
little justice to the multi-faceted
experience of infidelity oh boy
it demonizes adulterers without pausing
to explore their motives right because
sometimes motives don't matter you
committing adultery is not a good thing
if you want to cheat on your spouse
maybe instead of cheating on your spouse
you should control yourself or have a
discussion with your spouse or get
divorced if your marriage is that
failing it focuses on the traumatic
effect of affairs that acknowledging
their generative possibilities I love
this adultery isn't just something we
should overlook or pretend away it's
something we should celebrate she writes
to look at strings simply in terms of
its ravages is not only reductionist but
also unhelpful Affairs can be
devastatingly painful for the ones
betrayed but they can also be
invigorating for marriages yes I would
like to see a statistical study on how
many Affairs were invigorating for
marriages this is a bunch of crap
that is pushed forward by the left media
it's another one of these
yeah charles murray has a is a great
book okay I believe it's called coming
apart all about how basically there are
a bunch of white liberals who live in
big cities who don't abide by their own
sexual morality that they propagate to
the rest of society the but basically
the Murray's thesis is that if you look
at the perspectives on marriage in Los
Angeles in New York among the
upper-class
liberals what you will see is that they
are all married and they all stay
together for the most part and they all
do not commit adultery they acted in
traditional sexual ways basically in the
big cities contra to these stuff they
put out on TV and then people who don't
know better imitate that and they end up
with unhappier lives this is one of
Marie's thesis and I think it has some
some real heft to it in any case this
author writes Affairs can be
devastatingly painful for the ones
betrayed they can also be invigorating
if couples could be persuaded to take a
more sympathetic less catastrophic view
of infidelity they would she proposes
have a better chance of weathering it's
occasional occurrence when people ask
her if she is for or against affairs her
standard responses yes oh yeah I can't
see how this would go wrong in any way
peril whose belgian-born but practices
in New York is much sought-after for her
sophisticated European flavored insight
since 11 designer because clearly if we
want to look to a society it has a
sexual a healthy sexual ethos that has
not resulted in a mass drop in the birth
rate and the importation of people from
third-world countries in order to
fill the labor gap that's been created
you know if we if we want to look to a
place that has completely destroyed the
institution of marriage and has and has
therefore reduced the possibility of
happiness for a great number of people
perhaps you should look to Europe Europe
is duh like I always look to the French
I always think the French though those
are the people who I'm looking to for my
sexual morality mating in captivity the
book that brought her public notice was
a sprightly disquisition on the anaphor
the an aphrodisiac effects of married
life in which she argued that the
excessive value placed on communication
and transparency and perón see in modern
relationships tends to foster kanjou a
conjugal coziness at the expense of
erotic vitality her suggestion that
couples seek to sustain their Elan vital
would do well to cultivate a little
distance and mystery was not originally
a particularly radical no it is not
original or radical the idea that you
know you and your wife don't have to
share everything with one another
because that sort of kills the mystery
there that's not new I mean if you if
you watched the musical The Fantasticks
that's actually one of the the
concluding lines of the musical The
Fantasticks which came out the 1960s but
what she also says that adultery is
basically okay in many situations says
she's been accused of trivializing the
scourge of infidelity and of promoting
ideas that are fundamentally hostile to
the institution of marriage it's
difficult to find any real evidence for
these charges peril is more sanguine
than others about the capacity of a
marriage to withstand adultery lapses
but her belief in coupledom is never in
doubt she takes a very stern line on
what she sees is the excessive sense of
entitlement that contemporary couples
bring to their relationships so this is
the part I agree with right that you
have to work in marriage that you have
to that you have to actually you know
work at your sex life like these are
these are things that I think are
important in marriage because the level
of passionate as Jonathan Hite says the
level of passionate love in a
relationship starts off here at the top
and declines over time and level of of
couples ship basically a trust in
marriage increases radically over time
companion in love that that makes it it
moves it in in a very you know in a
companionate direction all of that is
true but saying that adultery is
therefore okay is really ridiculous she
says she wants to address or traditional
bias against cheating spouses to
acknowledge the point of view of both
parties what it did to one and what it
meant to the other in practice it must
be said her method seems to demand
heroic levels of forbearance
on the part of faithful spouses yes that
would be that would be true
that is exactly right but you know the
entire idea of the left is that we're
going to
rewrite all of the sexual rules and then
it will have no impact it will in fact
make things better it has not made
things better for the great majority of
people okay so I near now need to break
from Facebook and YouTube I believe some
things I like things I hate the big idea
coming up a lot of fun things so we'll
talk about all those things first you're
gonna need to subscribe $9.99 a month
will get you a subscription to daily
wire.com that will bring you all of your
favorite things in life it brings you
the rest of the show live on video
brings you the rest of man drew Clavin
show live on video the rest of Michael
Noel's show live on video we're doing
the mailbag tomorrow if you want your
questions answered in the mailbag you
can do that all you have to do is go
over to our daily wire bay page and
subscribe also when we do these episodes
of the conversations where I where I do
my full-on Q days then you get to ask
questions there you don't just have to
watch you also get to ask questions
we're also gonna have discounts in the
Shapiro store which I promise is in the
works it's happening stop asking it's
happening okay so you can get all of
that plus you get this the very greatest
in all beverage vessels the left is
tears hot or cold tumblr we are in the
closing days I believe of the West's
tears hot or cold tumblr right pretty
soon we're gonna change the giveaway so
if you want the leftist here's how it'll
call tumblr you need to it now like rush
to do it it makes for a great Christmas
or Hanukkah gift Kwanzaa gift if that's
your bag I do Molly whatever it is that
you celebrate this time of the year then
it makes a great gift for that check it
out you can get $99 a year it gets you
the annual subscription so cheaper than
the monthly subscription also if you
just want to watch later go over to
iTunes SoundCloud please leave us a
review it really does help make sure
also to subscribe to our YouTube channel
or we have brand new videos coming out
we're filming a new one today that is
patently absurd it's it's going to be
insane like fully crazy but you can only
really see it if you subscribe to our
YouTube channel so go over and do that
as well we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
all righty time for some things I like
some things I hate and then the big
ideas so things I like we've been doing
Beethoven music all week but not the
famous symphonies we've been doing other
things so this is from Fidelio so
Beethoven wrote one opera
he's called Fidelia it's a it's a
troubling it's a troublesome opera in
the sense the Beethoven had to rewrite
it a couple of times he kept going back
and changing the plot the basic plot of
it is that there is a man who's been
wrongly imprisoned the governor of the
prison is the bad guy he's a tyrant and
he basically wants this woman that this
woman tries to break her husband out of
president prison I believe if I recall
the plot correctly the the warden of the
prison makes an offer that if she sleeps
with him he'll release her husband I
think that's right in any case she ends
up she's the hero she's the heroine of
the of the of the she called herself
Fidelio but she is a woman she disguised
herself as a man to try and break her
husband out of prison but the the best
aria from this opera is the prisoners
course it's become famous and it's it
has a real resonance in an era when
prison camps still exist in an era when
they're still tyrants who are
imprisoning vast numbers of people for
political purposes this guy is a
political prisoner in the in the Opera
there's a little bit of the prisoners
chorus from Fidelio
the prisoners have been let out and now
they first they they actually get to see
the light from first time in months
[Music]
because this thing that hub this is the
first time they've seen the light months
and it's the glory of the light and the
glory of freedom this this was so
controversial at the time when Fidelio
first came out that was only performed I
believe once or twice when it first came
out because the governor of the region
was afraid that it was too political
that it was it was trying to cast doubt
on his control over the area and Bay
tone was an intensely political guy
right the most famous story Beethoven
being political is that whose admirer
originally of Napoleon whom he felt had
brought an end to the French Revolution
but had also wanted to spread freedom
and secularism around Europe and
tolerance around Europe and then so he
dedicated the Eroica his massive third
symphony which changed the face of music
forever he dedicated that originally to
Napoleon Bonaparte and then when
Napoleon declared himself Emperor then
he basically said that Napoleon is just
another Pig who wants to have power and
he scratched out Napoleon's name on the
cover page of the Eroica the original
copy of the Eroica he scratched it out
so hard that there's actually a hole in
the original cover page of the Eroica
so Beethoven was a guy with with some
pretty strong political views okay time
for a couple of things that I hate so
the thing that I hate today is that CNN
said something patently ridiculous
yesterday so yesterday somebody tweeted
out something nasty a president from
from Anderson Cooper's account at CNN
and CNN claimed that Anderson Cooper had
been at the gym somebody went to his
phone took his phone out unlocked it
tweeted something nasty at Trump put it
back in the locker and left it there
yeah that's not plausible the real
answer is that probably half the people
who tweet for Anderson Cooper are not
Anderson Cooper right that is not
surprising you know those of us who have
big social-media followings I handled my
own Twitter but I do have people who
post for me for example on Saturdays
like I'm not the one posting on my
Facebook account on Friday night and
Saturday because I don't use my computer
at that time so you know that it's not
unusual for Anderson Cooper's assistants
to probably tweet stuff out on Anderson
Cooper's behalf somebody who worked for
him probably mixed up his own Twitter
account with Anderson Cooper's and then
tweeted it out CNN didn't want the
blowback so they blamed it on some Rando
at the gym who stole Anderson Cooper's
phone in order to in order to smack
Trump or something that's really stupid
and and it's foolish of CNN to lie
because that's an obviously transparent
lie again it
their credibility at a time when the
media really need to be pretty solid in
their credibility considering the level
of doubt that's been cast upon them so
sorry I never do this but I want to go
back because there are a couple of
things that I like that I actually
missed today so there's there's one
thing I like particularly that I need to
show you this is just great so there's a
wrestling match and in between I guess
these kids are maybe seven years old and
one of the kids siblings is in the
stands two-year-olds and the
two-year-old thinks that that his
brother is in and his sister isn't an
actual fight like she's in a wrestling
match and so the brother thinks his
sister is in an actual fight and so the
little brother does what what all men
should do he rushes to the defense
here's the video so if you can't see it
these girls are having a wrestling match
and here comes the two-year-old rushing
in boom
taking down so the he rushed in to
tackle the boy it was it was a boy-girl
wrestling match I guess cuz the kids are
still young and the the two-year-old
rushes in and just takes down the boy I
mean that kid has a future
dad that kid is a stud and that's you
know they say that some kids are
sheepdogs and some are sheep that kids
the sheepdog right there love that I
hope that my little boy does the same
thing if ever my girl is in a fight I
hope that my little boy rushes in and
kicks me that'd be that'd be wonderful
one other thing that I liked this you
just have to laugh at this kids are so
wonderful and this is why I'm so so
adamant about guarding their innocence
because kids have a it doesn't mean that
kids are good because they're not always
good kid can be little craps but kids
are innocent and the fact that they are
innocent is what makes them so charming
is that they can be mold and shape to be
civilized adults and leaving them to
their own devices is foolish this is
super cute so there's a Christmas
pageant to the church and they they
wanted the kids to play the various
parts so they have one of the kids
playing a sheep a little girl playing a
sheep in the manger and and it went all
wrong here's what it looked like
so the sheep just got up and stole baby
Jesus and they made a run for it
she's rocking the baby like how the
little girls rocking the baby okay and
then here comes Joseph to try and shove
that baby back where one of the major
and try and shove that baby back down
all right
the Sheep won't have it so they're
having a full-on fight Jesus is being
kidnapped the AMBER Alert for baby Jesus
and and then finally Mary got rough
pretty spectacular they get in a fight
over preserving baby Jesus in there the
kids just singing pretty amazing okay so
I will say this one of the things that
is also very charming that he's
politically incorrect but is true is
that that is a little girl and you can
tell she's a little girl because she's
cradling the baby she takes the baby out
of the manger and starts cradling the
baby I have a little son he's a year and
a half old he does not care about the
baby dolls my girl cares about the baby
dolls the only time my boy cares about
the baby doll is if my little girls
playing with it then the boy wants in
because he just wants whatever she's
playing with but if he has his choice he
will take like she has magic wands he
takes them and he uses them as swords
like he takes something he walks around
hitting people that's his thing so
there's a vast difference between little
boys and little girls okay quick note on
the big idea so every Thursday I talk
about just a bigger idea that you should
know about and I talked about the fact
that President Trump has the capacity as
president of the United States to direct
the end of investigations this has
always been true so Professor Peter
Markowitz at Cardozo
School of Law says that the president
has really strong powers on a
prosecutorial discretion he says quote
President George Washington personally
directed and numerous criminal and civil
prosecutions be initiated and that
others be halted it has been observed
that President Washington's control over
prosecutions was wide-ranging largely
uncontested by Congress and acknowledged
even expected by the Supreme Court thus
from the founding through the Civil War
presidents repeatedly invoked
prosecutorial discretion Authority in
both civil and criminal contexts and
repeatedly enacted categorical
prosecutorial discretion policies the
Supreme Court recognized and affirmed
these practices if Trump were to call up
Muller tomorrow and say I want you to
end this investigation he has full power
to do that that is not an impeachable
offense that is not a high crime it is
not a misdemeanor it is part of his
power should he do that he should not
you should just allow the investigation
to go
it's been fatally compromised at this
point for a lot of folks so it's not
gonna damage him
I think in a serious way even if some
sort of unless there's something serious
that actually happened I don't think
that there's going to be a lot of fire
to this particular smoke okay we'll be
back here tomorrow with the mailbag it's
going to part of that make sure to go
over and subscribe $9.99 $9.99 a month
or $99 a year and then you can ask
questions in the mailbag I'm sure that
we will have a chock-full mailbag
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex Zingara audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by Jo
opera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2017